[Müzik]
etkilendik değiştik dönüşüyoruz ya sonra
Yunan filozoferaknitos değişmeyen tek
şey değişimin kendisidir demiş
Gerçekten de öyle değil mi
dünya dört buçuk milyar yıldır değişime
dönüşüm içerisinde
Biz insanlar Konuşmayı beceremezken
artık
dünyada görüntülü konuşmalar başladı
Biz İnsanoğlu dört buçuk milyar yıldır
değişime dönüşüm içerisinde
mıyız bilmiyorum ama dünya yeni bir
sayfa değiştiriyor
teknolojinin büyük bir transformasyonla
yani değişim ve dönüşümle beraber dünya
bir sayfa değiştiriyor kabul edelim ya
da etmeyelim yeni dünyaya doğru
gidiyoruz
pandemi ile birlikte de bu yeni dünyada
iki farklı insan grubu oluştu
bir
değişim ve dönüşümlerden korku ve kaygı
Duyanlar ikinci grup ise değişim ve
dönüşümlerden
heyecan ve merak Duyanlar
heyecan ve merak çok önemli
heyecan ve merak her alanda çok önemli
Peki Geçmişte de böyle değil miydi
birinci endüstri Devriminin itici gücü
James Batın mucidi olduğu buhardı
hepimizi etkilendik
ikinci endüstri Devriminin itici gücü
Thomas edison'ın bulduğu elektrikti
hepimiz çok etkilendik
3 endüstri Devriminin itici gücü
bilgisayardı çok ama çok etkilendik
etkilendik
değiştik dönüşüyoruz ya sonra
bütün bu devrimlerde
değişimi ayak uyduranlar da olmuş ama
değişime karşı Duranlar da bir Çin
atasözünde değişim Rüzgarı başladığı
zaman
bazıları duvar inşa eder
bazıları ise Rüzgar değirmeni
her devrimde değişim ve dönüşümlerden
korku Duyanlar Yani duvara işadenlerde
olmuş ama değişime dönüşümlerden
korkmayıp merak duygusu içinde olan
heyecan duygusu içinde olan rüzgar
değirmenleri inşa edenler de
Ben hep ikinci gruptaydım
Her Adım atışımda heyecan ve merakım ön
plandaydı
Türkiye'nin ilk hologram merkezini
Memleketimi açarken de
daha kimse konuşmazken Z kuşağı ile
ilgili ilk kitabımı yazarken de
Türkiye'nin ilk Yapay Zeka toplum
kuruluşlarından birisini kurarken de
58 yıllık bir televizyon kanalında ilk
teknoloji programını yaparken de
Flower aşkı merak olarak tanımlar
Neşet Ertaş ise aşkınan koşan Yorulmaz
derler belki de sizler de bugün heyecan
ve merak duyduğunuz için buradasınız
dışarıdakilerden çok farklısınız
dönüşümlere geç kalmamak dönüşümlere
koşmak için buradasınız
aşkı merak olarak tanımlıyor Neşet Ertaş
ise aşkınan korur aşkınan koşan Yorulmaz
diyor
birinci endüstri Devriminin itici gücü
buhardı James Watt bunu gerçekleştirdi
James batta aşk olmasa heyecan olmasa
merak olmasa Biz devrimleri konuşabilir
miydik
aynı şekilde Thomas edison'da Bunlar
olmasa Biz şu an devrimleri konuşabilir
miyiz dedik
gördüğünüz Dörtlü
interneti icat eden Dörtlü
bu dörtlüde aşık olmasa merak olmasa
heyecan olmasa Biz şu an interneti ve
bir ve
konuşabilir miydik
konuşamazdık
konuşamayacağımız gibi de tabii ki de
tartışamazdık
Dünya büyük bir dönüşüm içerisinde dedik
ve 3 bu dönüşümü çok daha hızlandırıyor
Ben devrimler arasındaki farklılıkları
anlatırken Balıkçılık öğrenini çok
severim
geçmişte Orkinos avcılığı basit bir işti
balıkçılar balık tutmaya Orkinos tutmaya
giderlerken
Yıldızlara bakar Rüzgarlara bakar B
sefere çıkarlardı Bazen bu tahminleri
tutardı Ama bazen de tutmayıp
fırtınaları çok büyük tehlikelerle karşı
karşıya kalabilirdi tekneler bazen
Alabora olabilirdi ama günümüzde Orkinos
avcılığı artık GPS navigasyon
araçlarıyla dolu
uydu tarama sistemleri ile balıkların
yerini çok net bir şekilde
bulabiliyorsunuz Ve tabii ki de daha
fazla balık tutuyorsunuz teknoloji
hızlandırır hata azaltır ve 3 de
hayatımızı hızlandırarak dönüştürecek
birbirinden farklı teknolojiler var 50
milyon kullanıcıya ulaşmak için radyonun
televizyonu 22 sosyal medyanın bir yıla
ihtiyacı var ama artık Dünyada Üç buçuk
milyar internet kullanıcısı var ve 3 ile
beraber 50 milyon kullanıcıya Belki bir
saatte ulaşabiliyorsunuz
MP3 de dönüşüm çok hızlı geliyor buna
hazır olmamız lazım
ve büyücü bir Şemsi olarak düşünün bu
şemsiyenin altında onlarca kavram var bu
kavramların birincisi blockchain
diğer devrimlerin hepsini merkezi var ve
etki alanları belli ama blockchain
merkeziyetsiz bir alan oluşturuyor ve
bütün dünyayı bütün insanlığı
etkileyecek bir alan söz konusu metavors
hepimizin son aylarda sıkça kullandığı
kavram
hayatımıza Belki yeni girmiş gibi
düşünürsek de 30 yıl önce hayatımıza
giren bir kavram
2030 yılında yaklaşık 13 trilyon
dolarlık ekonomik hacim yaratacak
gizemli bir kavram ve uzun yıllarda Meta
virüsü konuşmaya devam edeceğiz ve oyunu
değiştiren güç Yapay Zeka
2025 yılından sonra her alanı
dönüştürecek Yapay Zeka herkesin
ilgilenmek zorunda olduğu bir kavram
Yapay Zeka
ilgilenenlerin başarılı olacağını
şimdiden söyleyebilirim
Yapay Zeka her alanı dönüştürüyor oyunu
değiştiren güç Yapay Zeka
ve 2030 yılında Yaklaşık 16 trilyon
dolarlık bir ekonomik hacim yaratacak
Peki yapay zekanın tarihine baktığımız
zaman
1950'li yıllarda çıkan bir kavram Allen
Turing John macarti İngiliz bilim
insanları bu kavramları ortaya atan
insanlar
yani 1950'li yıllar yaklaşık 70 yıl önce
yapay zekanın ortaya çıktığını ve
İngiliz bilim insanlarının bu kavramı
ortaya attığını söyleyebiliriz peki
Bu resimdeki kişiyi tanıyor musunuz diye
sorsam belki salonunun Büyük bir kısmı
tanımayacaktır
ya da cebinizde 10 TL var mı diye sormuş
olsam Belki çoğunuzda vardır ama 10
TL'nin arkasındaki ismi bir çoğunuz
bilmiyorsunuz
ben hemen size söyleyeyim
ordinaryus Profesör Cahit Arf
bu topraklardan yetişmiş bir değer
bu topraklardan yetişmiş bu değer
Anadolu kentinde Erzurum Atatürk
Üniversitesi'nde
daha yapay zekanın ilk konuşulduğu
yıllar
1950'li yıllarda
saatlerce süren Yapay Zeka Konferansı
veriyor
bu topraklar değişim dönüşümlere uzak
değil bu topraklar değişim dönüşümlere
hazır Topraklar Peki Cahit arf'ta aşk
yok mu heyecan yok mu merak yok muydu
sizce
bence vardı
ama bazen yalnız kalırsınız
belki Cahit Arf yapay zeka ile ilgili
çalışmalar yaparken 1950'li yıllarda
aşkına heyecanla merakına ortak
bulamamıştı Belki de ortak bulamadığı
için şu an ülkemiz teknolojide ilk 5'te
değil ama hiç üzülmüyorum Çünkü
aşkına heyecanla merakına ortak bulacak
karşımda yeni Cahit harfler görüyor
sizleri
bir kitap düşünelim
Bu kitabın ismi
yeni dünya olsun
Bu kitabın birinci sayfası
Yapay Zeka
ikinci sayfası Meta World 3 sayfası
blockchain olsun ya diğer sayfalar
bilmiyoruz
diğer sayfaların ne olacağını bilmiyoruz
dönüşüm çok hızlı geliyor
dönüşümün tam ortasındayız
ya Ayakta kalacağız ya yok olup
gideceğiz
birinci endüstri ikinci endüstri üçüncü
Endüstri ve bir ve 3 ve 5
sayıları bir kenara bırakalım
Sen Bizler bu dönüşümde masada mıyız
yoksa menüde miyiz karar verelim
teşekkürler
[Alkış]
[Müzik]